well right now there are jewish groups
inside the el aksa compound members of
the groups include jewish settlers and
ultra-nationalist and zionist
jews earlier today prior to their
arrival it would have been the first
time that
non-muslims would have been allowed into
the al-aqsa compound since the violence
we saw on friday but earlier prior to
the
hours the three-hour time window in
which non-muslims can enter the al-aqsa
compound the israeli police say that
they went in to the compound because a
barricade of sorts had been formed with
stones and other debris that was
blocking the entrance that non-muslims
used to enter the compound the
palestinian red crescent says so far
there are two injuries one person was
hit with rubber rubber bullets the other
was beaten we can certainly hear
sporadically some stun grenades and we
have been hearing that since i arrived
but it appears so far that things have
been calm
just to give people a bit of broader
understanding about what these jewish
groups are doing inside the compound it
is prohibited for them to pray or
perform any kind of rituals that would
create an even bigger be considered a
real provocation but they do have rights
to go inside the compound they do so
though under a very tense atmosphere on
friday more than 150 people were injured
more than 400 people arrested including
children human rights groups say that
was the largest unmasked arrest in one
hour one location in more than 20 years